donc monsieur le lieutenant gouverneur
du québec
ce président l'assemblée nationale
mesdames messieurs les nouveaux
ministres mesdames messieurs les députés
mesdames messieurs les maires madame et
messieurs les membres des communautés
autochtones mais là messieurs les
membres du corps consulaire
le secrétaire général du gouvernement
sur secrétaire général de l'assemblée
nationale et vous allez me permets de
salut ma mère de 89 ans dumont
[Applaudissements]
ma mère de 89 ans qui m'a tout donné
mais ce moment je veux saluer mes deux
soeurs hélène française je salue mes
deux fils xavier et victor ces voix qui
meurent n'inspirer mon épouse isabelle
sans qui tout se serait pas passé
et il va me chicaner parce que je le dis
là m'avait interdit de dire son nom mais
je veux saluer mon fidèle compagnon qui
est là depuis le début de la caq sens
qui ont serais pas ici aujourd'hui
martin koskinen merci
donc distingués invités mesdames
messieurs cette journée très spéciale
très spécial pour moi spéciales sur
terre pour plusieurs autres personnes
je vois dans cette salle beaucoup de
sourires je vois surtout un grand
sentiment de fierté d'avoir marqué
l'histoire du québec
ensemble je vous présente aujourd'hui un
conseil des ministres qui lui aussi est
très spécial à plusieurs égards d'abord
c'est un conseil des ministres paritaire
un conseil donc formé à 50% de femmes
des femmes de grande qualité de grande
compétence
un conseil qui reflète cette valeur
fondamentale au québec l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes mesdames merci
d'avoir accepté ces grandes
responsabilités
merci beaucoup
cette équipe aussi est spécial par le
nombre de ministres qui n'ont jamais été
ministre
en fait sauf marguerite et moi tous les
mails istres occupe cette fonction pour
la première fois
et je vais vous dire que je vois pas ça
comme un désavantage au contraire
gouvernement du québec a besoin de
renouveau gouvernement du québec besoin
de visages 9 qui vont jeter un regard
neuf et vous apporter ensemble un
immense bagage d'expérience de
compétence que vous avez acquis ailleurs
dans la société
je vous demande je vous demande de
mettre cette expérience cette compétence
au service des québécois au service du
changement
l'autre côté spéciale de ce conseil des
ministres et non important de ministres
qui ont une expérience d'entrepreneur ou
de gestionnaire certains analystes l'ont
déjà ailleurs remarqué et ça tombe bien
parce que l'argent qui nous est confié
pour les québécois peut et doit être
gérée de façon encore plus efficace avec
rigueur est pareil à geler dit souvent
l'acceptent pas que le québec soit moins
riche que le reste du canada
l'économie du québec peut faire mieux et
ça tombe bien on a une équipe économique
de rêve
[Applaudissements]
et quand je parle d'une équipe
économique de rêve je parle bien sûr des
finances d'économies mais je parle aussi
l'éducation l'agriculture d'énergie de
forêt relation canadienne relations
internationales tourisme emploi énergie
culture immigration développement
régional transport affaires autochtones
environnement je vous demande à tout le
monde de mettre vos compétences au
service de l'économie du québec pour
aller chez tous des québécois dans
toutes les régions du québec
les priorités de notre gouvernement sont
très claires elle se résume en trois
mots éducation économie santé en
éducation
où est mon jean françois et isabelle
notre engagement le plus important c'est
de s'assurer que chaque enfant québécois
puissent aller au bout de son potentiel
et
cette grande et noble ambition elle
passe par le dépistage précoce des
enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage par la création des
maternelles quatre ans par l'ajout de
professionnels dans nos écoles par
l'appui à nos enseignants par la
valorisation de leur profession par la
rénovation de nos écoles si on doit
légué une chose une seule chose au
québec c'est de donner à chacun de nos
enfants la possibilité d'aller au bout
de son potentiel
en économie on a promis pendant la
campagne électorale a pris l'engagement
de remettre de l'argent dans le
portefeuille des québécois en
particulier celui des familles mais
aussi celui des retraités qui ont de
faibles revenus
eric prépare-toi dans les prochaines
heures
on va se mettre au travail pour vous
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles au cours
des prochaines semaines
[Applaudissements]
on a pris l'engagement aussi d'augmenter
le niveau de richesse du québec en
augmentant les investissements des
entreprises en augmentant en
diversifiant nos exportations
j'ai commencé ce travail la semaine
dernière à l'occasion du sommet de la
francophonie en multipliant les
rencontres avec des chefs d'état et j'ai
insisté sur notre volonté sur la volonté
de notre nouveau gouvernement
d'augmenter concrètement nos
exportations
nos échanges commerciaux diversifier nos
marchés on va y travailler
on a une équipe de rêve pour y arriver
en santé quel trio extraordinaire notre
mission première consiste que lorsqu'un
québécois est malade il puisse voir
rapidement un médecin ou une infirmière
sans devoir engorger les urgences on
devra aussi traiter nos aînés en perte
d'autonomie avec toute la dignité qu'ils
méritent
on devra aussi parce que marilyn mais
mieux aider les parents d'enfants
handicapés
on devra mieux soutenir les proches
aidants
on s'y engage encore aujourd'hui
donc cessons nos grandes priorités
auxquelles je vais ajouter une sincère
préoccupation pour les défis
environnementaux
on a bien oui
on a bien reçu le message la population
pendant la campagne on doit en faire
plus pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
on va y travailler chantal à notre façon
de façon pragmatique en obtenant des
résultats
un autre engagement important qu'on a
pris c'est celui de déposer dans la
première année de notre mandat un projet
de réforme du mode de scrutin
cette promesse va être connu
on devra aussi préserver l'avenir en
gérant les finances publiques de façon
rigoureuse en éliminant le gaspillage en
donnant des services de façon efficace
devra aussi se montrer exemplaire en
matière d'intégrité et on devra assumer
notre responsabilité de fiduciaire de
cette longue histoire de nation de
langue française en amérique
donc notre gouvernement pour la
promotion notre langue commune de notre
culture de nos valeurs notre
gouvernement aussi été élu avec un
mandat clair sur la laïcité on s'est
engagé à interdire le port de signes
religieux pour les employés de l'état en
position d'autorité
on va respecter notre engagement
[Applaudissements]
il ne respecte respectueuse
quant à la communauté anglophone
historique est à cet égard il me fait
plaisir d'annoncer la nomination de
christopher ski
christopher est même restée feu et le
député de sainte rose à laval a souri
sera l'adjoint parlementaire du premier
ministre
il sera responsable du dossier des
relations avec les québécois anglophones
on voit aussi gouverner en prenant
compte là venez des membres des
premières nations
j'ai l'intention je pense qu'il a déjà
séduit les d'avoir des rencontres dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines je veux est allé avec vous des
relations respectueuses
je vous demande maintenant mesdames
messieurs les ministres de gouverner
dans un esprit de proximité d'humanité
et d'ouverture et pour moi c'est toi oui
[Applaudissements]
ces trois notions proximité humanité
ouvertures sont fondamentales pour moi
je veux qu'elle devienne la marque de
commerce de notre gouvernement
oui on a remporté une victoire éclatante
avec une majorité de 74 sièges
ça nous confère une marge de manoeuvre
grande marge de manoeuvre
on pourrait tenter de gouverner comme
bon nous semble
mais au contraire vous demande de
gouverner en obtenant l'adhésion du plus
grand nombre
d'abord l'adhésion des membres de la
fonction publique
oui on peut avoir un gouvernement qui
est plus efficace plus ans et plus agile
et je convaincu d'ailleurs que la
majorité des fonctionnaires les
enseignants du personnel de la santé des
membres du secteur public sont d'accord
pour offrir des services plus efficaces
aux québécois donc votre premier défi
mais là messieurs les ministres c'est
que les membres de la fonction public
adhère à nouveau changement faudra aussi
avoir l'adhésion à nos changements de la
plus grande partie de la population on
fera jamais l'unanimité
d'ailleurs y est hors de question de
reculer devant des groupes de pression
ou devant les secousses les premières
petites secousses mais pour changer ce
qui fonctionne pas
pour changer j'ai appris ça en face
c'est vrai du côté public pour changer
ce qui fonctionne pas suffit pas de
décréter faut aller chercher l'adhésion
du maximum de personnes et je veux vous
dire quand on a les québécois derrière
nous rien n'est possible
aujourd'hui on forme pas le gouvernement
de la cac
aujourd'hui on forme de gouvernement des
québécois de tous les québécois peu
importe l'allégeance politique
on va travailler pour tous les québécois
et je tiens à rassurer les gens de la
gaspésie de la côte nord et de l'ouest
de montréal
on ne vous oubliera pas en forme aussi
va gouvernement
donc la proximité c'est essentiel on
doit rester proche des préoccupations
des québécois
je vous demande de sortir vos bureaux
d'aller sur le terrain rencontrer
d'échanger que les citoyens avec les
entrepreneurs les enseignants les
médecins les infirmières et préposés les
malades les enfants et c'est mon
intention aussi comme premier ministre
de demeurer en contact avec les
québécois dans toutes les régions du
québec
donc je vous demande de faire la même
chose de sortie d'écouter notre
gouvernement doit être un gouvernement
pro activement
bien sûr le gouvernement et les membres
de la fonction publique doivent faire
respecter les lois et les règles mais on
doit changer des habitudes et des
attitudes l'appareil public doit exercer
son bon sens et son humanité
on a vu trop souvent des décisions
tatillonne se transformer en petite
tragédie parce qu'on avait évacué le bon
sens et l'humanité je vous demande de
travailler en vous servant de votre bon
sens et votre humanité auprès des
québécois
je termine en m'adressant aux québécois
ce gouvernement c'est votre gouvernement
ce conseil des ministres il est à votre
service
on va travailler de toutes nos forces
avec tout notre coeur pour vous offre
mais on va avoir besoin de vous si on
est 10 millions à pousser dans la même
direction
tout est possible
je termine en vous disant j'aime les
québécois et pour répondre à un homme du
moins ce père et toute ma vie je lai vos
convictions profondes que oui on forme
quelque chose comme un grand peuple
merci
[Applaudissements]